hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play this creature
now you guys have been asking for this
for a while and and to be honest I don't
really know anything about this mod
other than you guys saying I need to
play it now I play don't starve awhile
ago I did a series on it but I stopped
it because I felt like it was dragging
on too much I didn't feel like playing
it it wasn't fun for me to play
therefore act discontinued my series of
it but I mean if this is good hey I
could maybe see that problem picked I'll
start up again I could odd
what was that sound
good question whoa I should go check it
out wow it's just like a third-person
perspective so cool oh I can't wait here
anymore
I'm gonna try to call the helicopter I
left my flashlight for you oh there was
a period there see you soon
Sarah in my duffel bag this is really
cool I'll need these batteries in the
box here is there a flashlight in the
box got it but um I click the toggle
flashlight oh that is creepy it's so
cool it's awesome
this is quite impressive here alright
looks like I got to figure out what that
noise was this is really cool I didn't
even know this game engine could handle
a third-person perspective like this now
I don't know if this game is randomly
generated much like the actual don't
starve but it wouldn't surprise me if it
was and the purpose of it is still lost
to me because I don't know why or when
or how I'm here huh - tent poles and a
sign gots me a vest and something else
some tattered rags and a map free
helicopter roof transport simply amazing
somehow I don't think that this is
actually gonna be amazing
oh look at that look at that it's like
actually they don't starve the things
always tends to the helipad
whoa hey are you actually a real person
or do I need to be very scared of you
now let's be without eye at friend uh
hello get the lid away from me
hey don't run away from me okay see that
actually was a real person
January 9th the helicopter just dropped
us off this place is amazing and a tour
guide seems really nice it is so
peaceful out here no one for round four
miles you must build here okay so for
now I'm gonna follow the path to the
helipad there's apparently that's my
objective and this is really cool this
is excellent use of the UH this is very
going on there do I need to watch out
for something behind me or what anyway
this is excellent you Sylvie don't
starve engine I really like the stylized
nature of don't starve
it's just when I was playing it it was
fun at first and then it just kind of
dragged on for a bit but that's just me
the helipad is that way
alright I'm oh uh I'm trusting you on
this one hi buddy
huh friend how are you doing nice chair
I'm gonna just steal all your stuff and
then be on my merry way January 12
something rummaged our camp last night
things are getting weird I haven't seen
the Brazilian couple in days it's so
cold bill is trying to fix the general
say so is that bill I'm a latest fireman
bullseye Oh got a battery hi buddy
what's going on here hahaha ah that's
weird
alright then oh okay Wow
hello there looks like I'm in for a
treat in this one some things are quite
disturbing in these woods I'm gonna take
this path I don't see any signs pointing
me in the direction that I want to go
wait there's something in there right
there's something here there's a yellow
petal hi my camera just suddenly jerked
off to the right there garbage bag
please no body parts oh god there's
something rotten in there god damn it
it's probably body parts somebody closed
oh right then what is that red mark
there's a red mark on my map over there
is there what's gone now why was it
there huh
I heard that right there all right I
don't think the red marker actually
anything I'm gonna take a left here and
go up where's this your eye
hello mister sign to the helipad that
was very good play and then the noises
come get me I heard that I heard that
water Foster
I need to get a drink or something would
I do
January 14th bill went looking for the
Brazilian couple he still hasn't come
back I'm getting really scared there's
something out there in the woods we need
to get out of here I must find the guy
um I don't think that guide is here to
help you at all in fact I'm pretty sure
the guide is here to screw you over and
send you to your death at the hands of
this creature whatever it is this is
what I enjoy about these organs the
atmospheric build-up like subtle
jumpscares things that you don't expect
although I expected something at the the
one guy there well this doesn't seem
right what's going on here the road just
kind of ends hell okay guess there's
something up here no it's just a bunch
of dead ends
it's foliage that I don't think I can
walk through I don't even yeah I can't
walk through it okay what the hell
is that no no I went the wrong way I
need to go over there to the left cuz I
see a campfire pit over there okay
hello let's go listen maybe some
batteries cuz I'm about to run out
please and use any of this stuff
boots batteries in the boots something's
rotting in the boot oh great
fantastic what is this a Slenderman
don't look at what oh that what just
happened somebody happened my camera
just whipped around for no reason
running out of batteries I really need
to find something soon yeah
helipad is not that way you're lying
sack of crap maybe it was actually
pointing this way oh that is blood on
the ground I mean to be perfectly honest
um wait let me turn off my flashlight
cuz they're gonna fire here don't starve
always had a sort of creepy atmosphere
to it let me get something routing it
hunts those who stare what is this a
Slenderman okay what I thought I was
dead I thought I was dead you killed
that woman she was just alive like two
seconds ago
that's why she told me to turn off the
light but it didn't seem to help her
anyway so Oh would that scent legit
chills down my spine I'm not even joking
about that I thought I was dead for sure
huh
this is good I can tell why you guys
wanted me to play this
don't know why I hesitated Rika's my
previous giant pile of blood was a good
thing oh good another dead body where
the face is eaten off only the faces are
eaten off oh okay I'll look at it it's
got like a bird's face oh hello
thank you pretty he's getting pretty
hairy which way am I supposed to go it's
like an alcove off to the right I'm
gonna check it first I don't know why I
don't know why oh good another dead body
look oh god what fanny pack really
really okay those there's no point in
coming back here
there's no point I'm collecting notes
I feel very reminiscent of the
Slenderman but this is done much
differently so I appreciate the
differentiation what's that it's just a
rock
cat-boy doesn't want any it tour guides
bag with on the tour guide god dammit
helicopter manifest Russell
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah Jane Biggs
okay I've almost found all of the notes
Oh God I got got a backup there's a box
here there might be batteries in it if
gonna get me where just the frequency I
probably needed to know that 1 6 4 0.4
ok that was the last now what is it 1 6
4 0.4 what
what sick 40.4 who's the point of that
what was the point of that was it o-o
but jumped all of it whatever it is it
ripped to shreds
there's someone stop thank you why did
they leave it out here good question I
don't care there's a there's a thing a
weird thingy well was it helipad up this
way you better not be lying to me sign
oh I see it on my map okay all right
okay what's that one six four 0.4 is
that a radio looks like your radio take
a radio maybe we can raise somebody 164
0.40 you're dead bill okay you turn on
the beacon okay can I get some batteries
I'm about to there we go there we go
landing laid Caesar let the helicopter
can land Sol and let's go light them oh
I need to all I need to turn on like the
generator or something oh geez how do we
do that how do we do bad pack of
batteries all right I'm full up on
batteries got plenty of batteries oh
that I heard something sounded through
the woods out of what oh that's a
generator okay that's what that was yeah
we're done i'ma start already on well
baby come on baby do it for me
all right oh but that might be bad it
seems like this was a bad idea on the
like ah crap haha that reminded me of um
oh I forget what Amata was I collect a
nine out of nine notes yeah good for me
I got all of them that reminded me of oh
um it was an amnesia mod one of the
first I ever played it was either lacasa
or abduction oh I did a highlight of it
it was like also and I looked down
everything turned red that was like a
pentagram on the floor which is kind of
like everything and all done they're all
around me
oh ah there's so many of them that was
really well done all the people who made
this you got to make more that was
amazingly well done
ah I loved it I loved every single it
was good oh good
alright so anyway that's it then I got
nothing else to say it was really well
executed it was a creepy atmosphere the
monster was very subtle it had a very
Slenderman feel with that don't look at
it sort of thing but um it was well
implemented and very fit don't starve
style which I really enjoy I enjoy the
style of don't starve it's just it got
it dragged on for quite a bit for me so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
sticks
by the fire no one's go out into the
middle
they could kill me
juleps
sixty percent durable
but you chop that up my fire my fire I
do not want to be out in this